welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and after Loki episode 4 of season
2 what the hell happens now everything's
gone Victor timely is dunzo he's on top
of spaghetti and he is a spaghetti it
seems like the TVA is destroyed
everyone's dead are we okay where the
hell does this show go on from here as
we look ahead to episode 5 we're going
to talk about it because this is the
sneak peek where we take the temperature
of whatever we are watching while we
head into the next episode or look ahead
into this upcoming week of nerdom and
joining me on this episode moments away
from spaghettification on his end is
Tommy be told M
delicious a spaghetti is a dish best
served
timely yeah uh very bad timing for
Victor timley this episode they showed
his bones Tommy can you believe that
that was one of the more gruesome I mean
we had we had been spaghettify had been
a thing since uh they string cheesed Mr
Fantastic yeah so you know I wasn't uh
uh ill prepared for it but the way that
he became torn aunder like that was
truly truly devastating uh and I got to
say I liked it I liked it too it did
something for me I yeah this was like I
gave a standing ovation in the breakdown
because I can't believe Marvel actually
went through with this I think it was an
awesome move uh and it's just kind of
like it's exactly what you want a good
piece of Marvel content to do it's just
to kind of end you with such a spectacle
yes and to uh just leave you only asking
questions for how they top this yeah I
mean I certainly I I mean I'm left
completely baffled by where it goes from
here but I I'm excited to talk I'm
excited to peek into it sneakily uh and
by the way Tommy and I did start to talk
about this whole Victor timely moment uh
over on the break room Channel check out
our inside Marvel discussion with Mod on
that but yeah let's dive into it now as
we look ahead to episode 5 absolutely so
things seem kind of dire there at the
end of the episode that's probably
putting it lightly timely has been
turned into pasta the TVA seems destined
to be destroyed uh what comes next for
the TVA is the temporal Loom continues
to overload temporal Loom however you
want to say it I say it tempora like uh
like Owen Wilson Eric what's next for
the TVA yeah you know I I I've been
comparing this whole crisis that we
actually saw at the end of episode one
I've been comparing it to uh the hatch
on Lost in season two of lost every 108
minutes they have to punch in this time
code of the six numbers to kind of reset
the clock U but basically the idea is
the overloading electromagnetic
radiation is always there and you just
kind of have to like reset everything to
keep it at Bay and I feel like that's
what the temporal Loom is it's just
always kind of destined to be on this
Loop of always hitting this existential
crisis and so it's not it's like
Ragnarok for the TVA right yeah Ragnarok
is a cyclical event and we are now
witnessing the TV Ragnarok that's what I
think that wall of fire is for Loki now
Loki this Loki remember got extracted
from the sacred timeline before he saw
Asgard destroyed now he knows that
Asgard was destroyed from season 1
episode two how he's looking through the
apocalyptic events and he you know he
saw his life and his Destiny play out on
film Real projector but this is him
going through that right of passage so
you know if you look at lost Desmond had
to kind of punch it in and then he
become he became disillusioned with
having to do that and then at the end of
season two he has to turn the fail safe
key and it is a blowing up the hatch and
you're it's kind of a similar moment
where it's like whoa what happens now
and then season three begins with
Desmond just kind of popping up naked uh
and he can see Charlie's future he's
like I know how you're gonna die Charlie
and then uh and then and as the series
goes on Desmond becomes the most
interesting character to watch because
he becomes unstuck in time his
Consciousness is hopping around at
different points in his life and I think
that's where Loki is headed I think he's
going to be time displaced he's going to
be hopping around to different points of
his life and I think this show is gonna
loop back to the events of season one he
all the same players wow and I think
he's gonna be able to replay the events
of the Citadel he's going to try to talk
I don't know if he'll be Consciousness
displaced I think the way they've shown
it is time slipping I think he's going
to be time slipping to different parts
of his own history future and past wow
yeah that uh that makes a lot of sense
CU it does feel like it we we from what
we have left in the trailers we have to
see him go back revert to time slipping
once something reaches like a critical
mass like that it's like yep now now it
almost like it almost it's not after
life is the wrong way to explain it but
it is like now your spirit is roaming
somewhere else and I think now is
probably the time to see Loki's Spirit
uh or Loki himself slipping throughout
time uh and I'm ready for it Eric I'm
ready for it yeah do we think like where
else could Loki go like he could end up
in the Citadel or something like that or
he could end up in the void because
that's kind of what season one did right
like Loki we thought was dead and then
woke up in the void we have to get to
the void this season right like there's
no way we're not going to see the void
right well Ren Slayer got pruned and I
think she's going to be in the void we
know from Trailer footage at this point
we're just looking at what's left like
what other their footage is left from
the trailer footage I mean there's a
shot of Ren Slayer in the void facing
down elath oh right we know there's
there's a shot of Loki time slipping to
the jet ski parking lot yes um and
there's a whole there's a shot of like
the Chrono monitor screen that's
spaghettify there's some shots of Sylvie
in like either her flat or her record
store where like she's looking at a a
record player and that spaghetti fies or
she's just kind of zoning out with some
headphones on and the room around her
spaghettify and it's far as I know off
to look at the trailer footage again I
think that's all that's left so we've
got a lot more pasta it was National
pasta day two nights ago but it's about
to be intern Intergalactic pasta month
for the uh remainder of Loki so yeah you
know there is that function on the time
stick that uh normally it's orange and
that's prunin that's prudent mode but
you can turn it purple and that's like
slowmo mode slow mode yes uh and that's
what uh B15 used to like whack Loki on
the face and slow down everything for
him and I wonder if that could be
happening like we slew down into this
moment and Loki's turning away but we
just kind of like freeze time the way
that like the the ancient one froze down
her death in doctor strange and he just
saw those lightning bolts slowly work
their way across the sky that could be
what Loki does we're we're really in
like the 2.5 seconds before that
radiation wall hits him yeah and he's
able to like time slip in and out of
that 2.5 seconds oh yeah w wow like
almost as if the time slipping is like
an involuntary survival mechanism for
him now oh yeah it kicks back in yeah
like aight response yeah maybe some
future version of him is like saving him
from this moment yeah oh I love that I
my mind is going places now like you
know how in in Inception where the
bridge in the the rain level um like the
the van goes off of the bridge and they
have like you know a few seconds before
it hits the water yeah but the few
seconds are minutes and the I I love
that part God I got to watch Inception
again yeah I I think that's what we're
going to be here I think time slipping
is going to be like the deeper layer
that Loki goes into but like he hasn't
learned everything he needs to learn
from his life yet so he's going to like
be bouncing around to different parts of
his life to figure out like how he can
escape this or undo this moment I think
it's ultimately oh there's one other
shot we forgot it just came to my mind
um there's one shot from Trailer footage
where we and this isn't a spoiler
because it's in the trailer footage Loki
without a radiation suit walks out on
the gang way M toward the temporal Loom
so I think that's going to be the answer
maybe the answer is the fact that like
because the Mis minutes was reset that
the magic dampeners are off and that
Loki can kind of use his Frost giant
magic his Asgardian magic his frigo
witch magic to uh to put a protective
barrier around himself that might be
able to resist the radiation long enough
for him to get out there H yeah I I mean
listen I'm all up for fraking magic give
me some Renee Russo cameos as well while
we're at it you know yeah Tommy do you
think we'll get any big cameos like in
season one we got Jamie Alexander
playing Lady Sith yeah they we got a
ball of the Brave shout out in episode
three uhhuh could we get a Daniel Craig
balder show up on this show I mean they
mentioned the shout out we know that he
was ready they fit he's they fitted him
for the suit right like I mean that does
feel like they don't often um make those
mistakes right it's not often that
someone uh is mentioned without it being
a f like Owen Wilson knows who balder
the brave is right like and and it seems
to imply that he knows that from noris
mythology but is it possible that uh
that Mobius uh his knowledge of just
time like Boulder the brave has appeared
to him at some point like is it possible
that he's seen Daniel Craig as Baler the
brave in some timeline who knows it's
it's like they all seem to have some
common knowledge of Norse mythological
figures right um like that's what Ren
Slayer used to just do the short-and
explanation to Victor timley in episode
three she's like okay so there's another
version of yourself and then they were
killed by two doppelgangers of the same
Norse godh because people know what the
Norse gods are you know that's like
common cultural understanding so it's po
but what was really weird remember at
the end of Loki season 1 how like B15
and mobus didn't even know what Aoki was
they were like a
what yeah yeah that's a good point uh
but but Mobius he seemed so after I mean
wooden carvings he was like he saw those
wooden pillars and was like okay that's
this person this person this person it's
meant to be played comedically but I
wonder if there's a deeper a deeper hint
towards a Baler Cameo I still feel like
if we're going to see Loki slipping
throughout his life we're primed for a
Chris Hemsworth Cameo it would be the
most surprising I don't know that they
need any iOS in this show I don't know
that they need them there's everyone I
mean the cast is so stacked with good
characters and actors just really I
think doing a great job at them but I
would I wouldn't I I would enjoy a Thor
Cameo other than that like I guess the
only other thing is because he seems to
like doing any and all Marvel things a
Hulk a Bruce Banner a smart Hulk Cameo
or something like that like like a
reunion between because of obviously the
iconic rag dolling of Loki from the
first AV movie some sort of reun between
that but you know I don't I certainly
don't need it and that to me would be
probably more of a distraction I'm I'm
not thinking too much about cameos I'm
more thinking about these characters and
then I know as you are but uh is there
any cameos that you've been uh pining
for we knew from deleted scenes that
Thor at least voiced throg for season
one for Chris Hemsworth did I think
Chris Hemsworth is probably like he
feels a lot of pressure to get in like
crazy insane shape anytime he plays the
so I I wouldn't want to put that on him
just for a cameo but like if there's
like a vocal thing you could do just
like a quick thing you could do or maybe
get back in the fat suit or something
like that be fun uh I mean balder I mean
seeing Daniel Craig show up as balder
would be my dream because here's the
deal like I think Marvel probably I know
they view the TV series The streaming
series as not as important as the movies
uh which maybe they aren't but but for
Daniel CRA I mean for Daniel Craig to
show up in a movie would be a big deal
he's a he's freaking James Bond James
Bond one the biggest movie stars yeah
literally James Bond would they put him
as Boulder in a streaming series
probably not probably not but yeah I uh
I just like how much this show reminds
us that despite it being a A Douglas
adamn sci-fi work comedy it is a show
about nor Scots yes um so he remind
Sylvie and was it episode three when
he's like we are Gods yeah it's episode
four yes episode four yeah sorry yeah uh
but you're right no that moment to me I
was like ah where he's reminding her of
the the plot points from the 2011 Thor
movie uh and how Thor became worthy
through his weakness I just thought was
I love how much we see this on the show
yeah and also you know Loki the
character Tom hson has played Loki as
this iteration through the TVA as
someone who has changed or seemingly
changed so much right like we almost
believe Loki has become so much more
human and compassionate and empathy
pathetic whether that's real or the
ultimate trick that he's playing on us
uh is yet to be seen but it's like right
we are reminded through those glimpses
of like the the the power that Loki has
right I mean his power had been dampened
but now kind of untethered he really is
a terrifying demigod so I'm just loving
this show right now I don't need any
cameos I that's you know I don't want us
to be like when we were doing Ahsoka and
and covering Star Wars they are so
reliant on their cameos and I feel like
the MCU sometimes feels that pressure
but a show like Loki is so good like
isn't it crazy that when we watch season
one the fact that Jamie Alexander showed
up as lady CF was like just like the
14th or 15th most interesting thing I I
agree and I think it speaks to a more a
larger thing that I know both you and I
have touched on which is like enjoy what
we have in front of us with Marvel it's
not about what surprise Cameo or what
post-credit scene is coming take in the
main course enjoy what we're getting
from Tom Heston and Owen Wilson and all
the other fantastic actors on this show
uh and if you get a cameo great that's
uh that's some Parmesan on your uh
Victor timely spaghetti man we should
have had some pasta ready to go while we
I know I'm so hungry now uh I'm gonna
ask John I know you're listening can you
get can you GrubHub me a plate of
spaghetti Casta pasta it's in your
contract I thought he's an encer we we
got a call her body gorash yes to oh my
God gorash is on one of those electric
bikes that we were uh pedaling for a
while no pun intended gorash is he
doesn't know how to get off gorash has
been riding a hobco for 47 straight days
uh he just buzzes by once a day going
who's hungry who's
hungry I do not know the break I just
keep going faster quick throw sandwich
in mouth I catch sandwich with mouth and
spit out at you h
gorash is trapped on Loop of penro
stairs it's all down there's no op if I
didn't know gorash a kidney I wouldn't
talk to him
anymore well he's such a piece of
he's awful he doesn't ever uh invite us
over he only just asks if we're it's
always it's always where is gorash never
why is gorash
um all right uh we got to remind you
guys that the best to support us here at
new rockstars to grab some lowkey
inspired merch From Nerd riot. shop
Tommy and I are both spouting some
Marvel designs I got her Mobius pie
shirt that smells pretty bad but it's
just getting more comfortable because
it's merging with my skin but Tommy's
got some our flurin design for the
upcoming Marvel's film yes this is the
only time you will ever see me wearing a
cat shirt that isn't Garfield hey
Garfield also knows that it's always
pasta time that's right John you hear
that get us some lasagna yes I agree get
these shirts they're so comfortable the
mo the Loki designs are really I'll be
honest crowd-pleasers I get a lot of
compliments on those on the street yeah
I do too especially I I I'm not wearing
it now but we got this new OB shirt and
you guys got to see this it is awesome
that I'm going to be wearing that for
the rest of the year I got to get like a
little OB I'm going to just wrap my
newborn child in the shirt that will be
the child swaddling clothes is shirt if
you wear that OB shirt all year you're
going to have some real Bo but then you
mentioned your kid and I and I didn't
got all cute so yes let's swaddle the
Voss baby in in an OB shirt let's that
that child's going to be outfitted
exclusively by nerd Riot and and you
know what that child shall be wise that
child shall have a great future H so yes
please by all means subscribe to all
three channels of the new rockstars
Network by the way new rockstars the
Deep dive and of course the one near and
dear to my heart the break room so I got
a call from my bank recently asking me
whether or not I'd spent 15 Grand in
Vegas and yeah although I guess a
shopping spree in Vegas does sound nice
fraud sure isn't but the good news is
you know that your financial info is
secure just by using PayPal more than
422 million people were affected by data
compromises in the year 2022 every time
you buy something online your financial
information is logged on a new site with
new security protocols it's just too
much to keep track of for any one person
PayPal gets that which is why they work
hand inand with over 35 million
Merchants worldwide to help protect your
financial data payments and eligible
purchases adding your credit cards to
your PayPal app gives you access to 24/7
fraud monitoring Pass Key login Security
Financial encryption purchase protection
on eligible purchases and lets you send
money securely there's never a bad time
to rethink how to keep your digital
wallet safe and you can start right now
by using the link in the description to
download the PayPal app today all right
now Eric this episode closed the loop on
episode one's Loki prune we've all
learned our lesson on guessing who the
heck was pruning Loki cuz I feel like by
the end we all were on board with it was
Loki are we going to see I mean we kind
of alluded it to it in our last in the
last discussion more cyclical moments
like this or is that a oneandone gimmick
that we won't see more again I are are
we going to see some more time Loops
here yeah uh in fact uh let's spend the
next few days rewatching every scene
that happens in the TVA for every
character in the background because this
episode proved that like watching the
background details is important because
you could see Loki creeping up back on
himself this is like Back to the Future
part two if zamus really did shoot part
two at the same time as part one and hid
these little things in there I'm willing
to bet that we're going to find some
other examples of like background lokis
uh throughout the TVA of like future
instances where he's looped back on
himself just like quick flashes like uh
David Fincher flashing uh Brad Pit
throughout Fight Club um so yeah I think
we will see more time loops and I I'm
betting that we have already seen them
so so let's just rewatch ooh yes a
rewatch is mandatory now mandatory fun
play my
graphic I think Loki is one of the more
rewatchable shows uh that we cover at
new rockars I think the boys uh season
one but Loki uh for in terms of Disney
plus Marvel series oh my goodness I
could I could do a rewatch of that uh
once a month and and in fact I just
might yeah okay so now we've got to talk
about um
I I'll just say it someone who has
occupied my mind body and soul for for a
long time now miss minutes was rebooted
but not before telling Victor there's
something I need to tell you and then
just letting it be you'll never be him
so I don't know if that was really what
she meant to say do we think those
statements are connected or is there
something else Miss minutes wanted to
tell him but then the reboot just made
her Petty and angry or she just panicked
and was like you know what I'm not going
to have time to say it I'm just going to
say something mean you know that I
didn't think of it that way but that's
such a cool way to interpret it like the
reboot or the glitching caused some
other meaner side of her to flash in for
a second and that originally she was
going to say something like it was
something encouraging you know in the
breakdown I I posited that like her
saying you'll never be him was her way
of putting a chip on his shoulder to get
him to do something stupid because I
think that him hearing that is what made
him decide to be the hero and he did
something he did something and he did
the stupidest thing edly stupid I mean
the the real like we talked about what
makes a Loki a Loki what makes a he
remains a he remains is the fact that he
remains he does not go out in the line
of fire like Leroy Jenkins he hangs back
and lets someone else jump on the THS up
let's do this ah my God so by saying
you'll never be him she was creating a
self-fulfilling prophecy because he
didn't realize what him means uh you'll
never be him he decided okay well I
think to be him is to be a hero but no
to be he remains is to be a coward and
to let someone else jump on the grenade
so my read of that moment is that she
knew what she was doing and that she
knew the future of what would happen by
him uh like she told him the worst
possible thing to tell someone who you
want to remain well and and the look on
her face The Way She was drawn the the
like the just
pure anger and and hatred in her eyes at
him like you'll never be him you know
it's like it was said with so much uh
acid you're right it was it had its
exact desired effect I was going to ask
you didn't it feel like a call back
actually to episode three when she was
rushing at him and then he switched her
off and then when Rin turned it back on
she was like love you oh like I think
that was a call back to that so we think
that she's gonna say I have one thing to
tell you I love you but instead it's I
have one thing to tell you you'll never
be him unless you go on the suicidal
mission unless you unless you serve up
NeverEnding pasta Olive Garden style now
Eric I'm G to ask this followup and God
I hope the answer is uh somewhere not in
the two options I give you is Miss
minutes dead or is she just a baby you
know we saw her blink out because before
she became that old school clock what do
we think is she is she is she reborn or
is she just a clock now
in a vegetative state I think she's in a
vegetative state I don't think we've
seen her final form I think Miss minutes
is going to come back in the final
episode in her most monstrous form yet
and her most dangerous form yet I think
Miss minutes is the villain of this
season I I have no doubt in my mind that
she is the villain of this season I
can't wait she has the been the most
frightening character she's been the the
way she reacted when those people got
crushed in the cube like that is the
most evil expression like even Thanos
didn't take that much Jo no Thanos was
like this is just something I have to do
so I can go make my
soups you know what's missing from that
soup is a side plate of pasta yeah oh I
love soup with pasta Incorporated
ministr yeah oh yeah oh yeah all right
okay I'm getting horny for soup you know
it's a Thursday when I'm getting horny
for Soups I think we got a back up to to
Northern California and go with their
friends from the kyber cave crew
remember that that's right yes go to the
who hooked us up with some Olive Garden
that was one of my favorite memories of
2020 I had a legitimate amount of bread
sticks that night that I think can't be
understated H or overstated awesome I
yeah awesome you know Eric next time
you're down here we got to go to the
Burbank uh Super Walmart and uh go to
that Olive Garden when you're there did
you you know this your family and did
you know that I recently found out
through Tik Tok you can buy the the
parmesan cheese Romano grater they sell
those and if you buy it they'll give you
a little uh takeaway thing of the cheese
that they use so you can sample it when
you get home now for that's fascinating
to know I want to ask in The Grater of
the parmesan to grade it into these
stringy forms do they just have a core a
column core of Parmesan that's in there
that you spiral down I think it's a I
think it's a temporal Loom uh no it's a
no they just you just put little it's
it's like one of those cylinder yeah
like what you're saying it's like the
it's like the the the um the
self-playing pianos where you have to
put the tubes in that have the grooves
to play the notes they put one of those
tubes in and then it and then it uh
stringify the
cheese yeah so it spag ifies the cheese
you yeah so it really is a loom as I
said it's a there's a temporal Loom guys
Eric we're going to bring we're going to
bring a camera crew to Olive Garden and
you and I are going to and you and I are
going to get down on the the cheese
Shredder uh will it be anything
productive for the channel no will it be
delicious and we can write it off or
charge a company card yes and that's
what it's all about oh it's a greeting
card that just says pay up mother
uh you open it it just says ha you cover
the bill ah all right
oh my
God okay it is now time for our heat
check and it is hot on Loki right now I
gotta say looking ahead to episode five
I have no qualms whatsoever this show
has been I was talking to mod about this
last week it's just getting better and
better agree I didn't think it was going
to be this good for loky season 2 to be
honest without without Kate Haron
without Michael M now I don't know if
it'll end up being better than season
one cuz season one was almost Flawless
uh we still have two episodes for them
to screw things up but I just don't
think they will yeah this is like the
the most fun I've had in Marvel I think
since season one of L yes I agree I
think uh when I did the rewatch with
John uh I really I I had forgotten how
much I enjoyed uh season 1 but what it
really did was it set me up into a great
place to start enjoying season to and I
felt like they they picked up so quickly
right where they left off they explained
things in a way that was interesting it
didn't feel cheap and then it since then
it's just been uh a lot of fun some
really really great performances and I
just like where the story's going I'm
excited uh you know I I I'm a little bit
I'm almost kind of in a really
refreshing way completely Gob smacked
about where the show is going to go like
I don't know and that could even mean
the recasting of Kang now no this show
won't do that but no could you imagine I
mean do you think we talked about this
bit on inside Marvel I just think they
might some bfx artist might have shown
his bones just to give Marvel that
option yeah they're like he he's gone
yeah I I don't know I mean it's such a
tricky situation the only thing I could
say as a zag is that like at the last
minute Loki does like he holds up like a
prune stick and he's just pruning all
the energy around and and as I've I on
our Doomsday Clock show I just keep
predicting that the entire thing is an
illusion and that the TVA is just
created to keep these variants terrified
from uh from rejoining their lives on
the sacred timeline it's just like the
TVA is a prison and it's just it's a
prison of of Illusions and like
hyperrealistic uh um you know violence
and and pain and and all of these things
and food and everything feels so real in
there but it's still just one Kang
keeping them all prisoners so that they
don't with his timeline and uh and
so if Loki is just pruning it in real
time as it's going around him and then
it's just we see like uh immortis or
Scarlet Centurion or one of those like
horrible kangs it's like all right you
figured it out the TVA is all fake you
guys are all prisoners even the ones you
cubed you're cubing yourselves you're
look at the mirror you are the Cuban and
that's the only crazy thing I could see
I like your Cuban it's Mark Cuban
and it's a Cuban sandwich and it's a
Cuban cigar he's like you thought it was
Italian night it's it's Mark Cuban
eating a Cuban smoking a Cuban drinking
a cubba Libre uh you know what I think
is we're gonna pan out and instead of it
being the TVA it's going to be that
weird shot and secret invasion of all
the people in the gurns in the basement
yes oh my God and everyone will be
pissed John Costa will just pour lighter
fluid on himself John Costa will self
imilate in a a steaming bucket of
marinir he'll he'll he'll pour it over
his head and he'll burn it like um like
uh like daus's brother in h season one
of Game of Thrones a pasta Fit For A
Casta oh man that delighted
me we'll leave it there for this episode
of the sneak peek uh this has been a
delight being able to celebrate Loki
with you Tommy all season long likewise
and I'm saying this now because next
week who knows next week we could be in
morning we could be wearing we're
wearing black now but we could be
wearing black veils by the way we should
wear black veils anyway like the little
girl from the others with Nicole Kidman
are you mad I am your daughter I am your
daughter oh yeah that this has been a
delight Tommy be sure to follow Tommy at
Tommy Beck told on Twitter and on all
social media we'll see you next week for
the sneak peek follow me at eoss uh and
have a great week everybody bye-bye
[Music]
bye
w